[Applause]
[Music]
the Board of Trustees and the Faculty of
Carnegie Mellon University together with
the staff students alumni and Friends of
the university are convened here today
October 26 2018 to celebrate the history
and traditions of our institution and to
look forward with the inauguration of
the 10th president of Carnegie Mellon
University dr. Farnum Johanna Yin
ladies and gentlemen please rise for the
national anthem sung by alumnus Cory
khat accompanied by Professor Gary Klein
[Music]
by the dawn's early light
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
that was great Thank You Cory how about
a round of applause for its Hartman
getting a sign please be seated
good morning and welcome everyone all
right
Farnham I don't know about you but it it
feels good to be here this morning good
about that I was a wonderful place to be
exported thank you all for being part of
this wondrous celebration of a
transformative moment in CMU's history
and a pivotal time for Humanity the
digitalization of information and the
democratization of knowledge and the
unprecedented access the data and
analytics are driving societal change at
a spectacular pace the scope scale and
ubiquity of these technologies are
revolutionising every sector of our
economy including finance healthcare
transportation energy manufacturing
education and yes the arts the
trailblazing work of our faculty and
students has positioned CMU at the
leading edge of human progress
there has never been a more say exciting
time to engage in research and work that
matters the potential for profound
impact is extraordinary and we at CMU
have a long tradition of excellence in
our bold visual arts music and theater
programs and we continue to define them
and manage the space where our humanity
intersects with technology
CMU not only embraces the new paradigms
we define them our university recruits
diverse perspectives and ideas to
advance human knowledge and pursue new
modes of creative expression here at CMU
we dismantle the silos restricting
forward momentum and we help people from
all walks of life to succeed when we
consider ideas from across the grand
spectrum in a culture of civil discourse
we all win the things that make our
community unique have never been more
valuable than they are
now the future of Education in the 21st
century will depend upon breaking down
disciplinary silos it will be forced by
diverse minds coming together and
learning and research as an institution
grounded in relentless creativity and
driven by fearless entrepreneurial
spirit Carnegie Mellon new University
knows how to do this better than anyone
education is the key to staying ahead of
the fast-moving current to make the most
of opportunities that lie ahead we must
be willing to disrupt the system of
higher education itself and to do that
we need a bold leader the single
greatest responsibility of our Board of
Trustees and thank you so many of you
for being here
is to select the president who can guide
our University dr. Farnum jahannum is
the right leader at the right time to
guide our great University forward a
Providence scientists creative
entrepreneur public servant and esteemed
educator Farnum Jahan Ian brings the
experience passion and leadership
necessary to steer CMU now each of us
has a role in his success here as we
charge him with the fantastic work of
magnifying the societal impact of
scientific discovery emphasizing our
leadership and creative expression and
building the skills students need for a
lifetime of learning I ask all of you
and each of you to join me in supporting
him in his efforts to meet this
strategic vision now it's a great honor
for me to introduce one of our
university professors who are the most
one of our most senior members of our
faculty dr. Marlene Berman who is the
Thomas X Stockton Baker University
professor of cognitive neuroscience and
the first CMU woman elected to the
National Academy of Sciences Marlee
[Applause]
good morning it is a true privilege for
me to participate in this investiture
ceremony
I came to CMU in 1993 expecting that my
sojourn in Pittsburgh would last just a
couple of years this year marks my 25th
anniversary even after trying to move to
Toronto to be closer to my family in
2006 CMU exerted its magnetic pull and
drew our family back after a brief six
months I've served under three previous
presidents at CMU and am delighted to
join you in welcoming the university's
tenth president dr. Farnum Gahan Ian
I also take much pleasure in welcoming
dr. hon Ian's wife tres whom I have come
to know over these past few years as
well as all the members of the Jehan Ian
family
I am truly honored to have been chosen
as a speaker for this August
ceremony and am unreservedly supportive
of dr. Jehan Ian I have witnessed him
close up in action over the last four
years and have observed his gracious
behavior even on those occasions when
I've been a thorn in his side
particularly remarkable is that dr.
Jehan ian takes time to listen to the
multiple constituencies that make up CMU
i served as a co-chair of the task force
to enhance the students experience as
provost he not only initiated this task
force but he remained supportive and
involved in its work even when he was no
longer Provost stepping back I am struck
by how CMU has evolved since my first
year here way back in 1993 it is truly
staggering some of this evolution is a
result of the expansion and growth of
the physical setting of the campus and
the recruitment of outstanding new
faculty staff and importantly students
but this evolution is reaping the
benefits of hard work done over
generations to build CMU as an
educational and research powerhouse and
as links in the chain of this ongoing
community we have all forged a common
bond with a perpetual commitment to
improve the students experience to
enhance the educational opportunities to
engage our alumni and to conduct
cutting-edge research that makes a
difference to ask
xiety and our world I'd like to share
with you a comment made to me a couple
of weeks ago I was having lunch with a
junior in mechanical engineering Alex by
courts and in discussing CMU he said it
just does not get better than this and
he is right my personal commitment to
the institution is clear to my husband
David Plante who is also a faculty
member here and I have entrusted CMU
with the education of our own children
it just does not get better than this
we're a CMU family through and through
and so as we begin this new chapter in
the evolving book of Carnegie Mellon
University my colleagues and I dedicate
ourselves to continue building an
institution of the very highest caliber
with a commitment to an inclusive and
equitable campus for all of its members
and with opportunities for all to
realize the educational and research
potential dr. johan ian has clearly
expressed his commitment to facilitating
these initiatives and we are also
excited to see what comes next thank you
[Applause]
now I am pleased to welcome to the
podium dr. Amiya Krishnan Dean of the
Heinz College of Information Systems and
public policy Thank You Marlene good
morning I'm delighted to introduce our
next speaker
Keith Locke it's a great friend of mine
personally but also a great friend of
the University and of the Heinz College
Keith is a distinguished alumnus of the
Heinz College a member of my Dean's
Advisory Council and a member of the
Board of Trustees
he's also co-ceo of Salesforce and
member of their board of directors keith
serves and has served in a number of
important roles
he's the company's vice chairman
president and as a director since
joining the company in June 2013 and
additionally served as a company's chief
operating officer since February 2016
clearly a multi-dimensional
multi-talented person as president and
CEO of Salesforce Heath oversaw the
company's multibillion-dollar global
sales and services business alliances
and channels industry strategy corporate
development corporate affairs marketing
and business operations in February 2018
Keith and his wife Suzanne established
the block Center for technology and
society at CMU this important center
which is cross-cutting in university
wide will foster critical dialogue on
campus to create inclusive and
meaningful plans of action on topics
such as the future of work and issues of
trust and transparency in the use of
autonomous systems to improve the
quality of life for all keith holds a
Master of Science degree in management
and policy analysis from behind
College and a bachelor's degree in
information systems from Dietrich
college so he was ahead even then at
being at those nexus of technology in
society in addition to his membership on
the Carnegie Mellon University Board of
Trustees he's also currently a member of
the World Economic Forum's Information
Technology community as a governor and
on the advisory board of our Heinz
College and its board of trustees of the
Concord Museum please join me in
welcoming Keith block to the podium
[Applause]
well thank you krishnan you've made me
blush this morning so I appreciate that
and thank you very much for that very
kind introduction so first I want to say
good morning everybody
okay that was my best Farnum I gave it a
run my friend anyway good morning to
everybody
faculty alumni staff family and friends
it is an honor to be here today to
celebrate the investiture of a great man
dr. Farnum Jahan e'en as president of
Carnegie Mellon University in all of
life's endeavors Farnum has led with a
tremendous spirit in an unrivaled
dedication whether as a world-renowned
computer scientist a passionate
successful entrepreneur a tireless
public servant or a world-class leader
in higher education and oh by the way
just an incredible incredible human
being now I've had the opportunity to
work very closely with Farnum and we
have shared many experiences around
career and our life journeys including
everybody's favorite Parenthood and
Farnam by the way that advice you gave
me about curfews for teenage kids thank
you so much for that I would never have
thought of that myself but thank
goodness it worked over the years we've
had a very very close relationship and
friendship and for that I'm very very
grateful professionally I've also had
the opportunity to observe Furnham in
his influence and guiding policy at the
World Economic Forum and I will tell all
of you he has represented this
university incredibly well I've also
witnessed his leadership here at CMU
personally with students and faculty and
staff and members of the board of
trustees and whether it's uniting the
community to support the special
olympics where i understand he has a
passion for dunk tanks do you just want
to come up and tell everybody about this
downtown
all right I'm sure you'll get to that at
some point or really fostering
engagement between students from
different colleges Farnum has a talent a
true talent for bringing people together
and breaking down walls Farnum is also a
leader with impeccable integrity and the
highest of character he conducts himself
with grace and dignity and
thoughtfulness and warmth there is no
question no question Farnum will guide
this institution into the future and
accelerate its impact on the world so
today we witnessed the passing of a
torch to an incredibly talented
individual now this torch has been held
by many many great leaders throughout
Carnegie Mellon's very rich history and
there have been so many accomplishments
and so many historic milestones since
Andrew Carnegie founded a Technical
School in 1900 individuals of great
character and honor have taken the reins
of leadership of this very prestigious
institution and each of them have led
with courage and vision names like
Hammer slag Dougherty Steven
sire Cohen those are but a few each of
these presidents and others of this
storied institution led through myriad
chapters in American history world
history the turn of the century the
Great Depression the explosion of
Technology that Jim was talking about
just a few minutes ago civil unrest war
and peace and throughout all of this
presidents of Carnegie Mellon have
guided this institution to the forefront
of educational excellence and they have
shaped the minds of so many young people
all the while ensuring that the
university remained a source of
inspiration a guiding light a beacon of
hope and now we pass this torch to
Farnum Jehan Ian there was no one who
was better suited to lead us into the
next chapter and this next chapter is
arguably the most important ever for we
do live in very very interesting times
we have seen and this is just the
beginning
but we have seen incredible advances in
technology we are at the dawn of a new
era some refer to it as the fourth
Industrial Revolution and this is where
we have the convergence the perfect
storm of social and mobile and deep
learning and artificial intelligence and
3d printing and amazing technologies all
brought together to drive incredible
innovation now like many of you I have
the opportunity and good fortune to
speak with other CEOs and world leaders
and what is top of mind in that group is
how to harness this wave of innovation
in a very positive way this convergence
of technology is having a profound
impact on our world we see it in our
daily lives it has also brought great
disruption and given rise to many many
questions what will these new
technologies be will they be positive
for mankind
what are the socio-economic effects what
are the privacy implications what will
be the regulatory issues what will be
the future of work and Farnam is
passionate about these questions and
even more passionate about CMU leading
the way to drive those answers to these
questions these are all important issues
of our time that we have to consider in
a thoughtful and meaningful and measured
way we are clearly at an inflection
point these advances must be for good
they must enlighten they must empower
and they must take humanity to greater
heights and in a world where there is an
ever-increasing divide these advances
must create opportunity for all not just
a few so that all of mankind can
participate and contribute now this will
take vigilance it will take dedication
and it will take leadership and this is
why the faculty the staff the students
this community at Carnegie Mellon are so
critical to the future of this nation
this society this world for the young
minds that we shape here have an
important mission they will go forth
into the world with the knowledge the
vision and the ethics that Carnegie
Mellon has instilled in them and they
will go forward into the world
to solve universal issues that lie at
the intersection of technology and
humanity the graduates of CMU must be
equipped to thrive and lead in the world
of uncertainty for these are truly
uncertain times today the value of trust
is being questioned more than ever
trust in technology trust in our
institutions trust in our leaders some
would say there is a crisis of trust and
this crisis of trust has created a
leadership void and now individuals and
companies and faculty and students alike
must fill this breach and it will be the
graduates of CMU that will answer this
call for leadership and for them it is a
call to arms it is a call to arms for us
all it is an obligation to lead in an
ethical and transparent way to engage in
constructive civil discourse where
disagreements will arise and that's okay
but dialogue must happen with respect
and while there can be differing
opinions there cannot be differing facts
and most important most important to
restore trust in our society because
without trust
we have nothing it will be the graduates
of Carnegie Mellon that will be called
upon to cultivate and drive a culture of
success in business and society where
the core tenants of diversity empathy
equality humanity accountability and
opportunity for all are at the forefront
never before has this institution been
more important to the world never before
has leadership at the intersection of
technology and society and humanity been
as critical as it is right now and
though the future is unwritten I am very
confident very confident that the
graduates of CMU will be the authors of
a great future for all of us now as we
stand at the doorstep of this new world
the dawn of a new era
we need a truly special leader to help
guide and shape the lives of those who
will determine the future all of our
futures a never before has a presidency
of this institution been as important as
it is right now and it requires a
remarkable leader a truly outstanding
human being
and that person is doctor Farnum John
Ian we stand with Farnum today as he
takes his rightful place amongst the
great presidents of Carnegie Mellon I
cannot imagine a better leader who
embodies the values of CMU I cannot
imagine a better leader with as much
vision with as much passion with as much
focus and I cannot imagine a better
leader in torchbearer of this great
institution Farnum we are very lucky to
have you you are the right leader as Jim
says at the right time so ladies and
gentlemen please join me in
congratulating a true friend a great
leader and the next president of
Carnegie Mellon University dr. Farahani
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Professor Gary Klein and alumna Tamara
Tunie accompanied by the School of Drama
choir performing how can I keep from
singing
[Music]
my life flows on in endless song above
the far-off you bad
[Music]
through all the tomorrow
it sounds
[Music]
can I
Oh
buh-bah Tempest
[Music]
what
[Applause]
[Music]
can I keep from singing
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow that is a miracle
whoo tomorrow thank you so much oh that
was just absolutely the choir and it's
absolutely spectacular thank you thank
you another round of applause
you're inclined Gary Klein thank you so
much I mean it's a you know when someone
shows up with a mace it takes the fun
out of the meeting really but I have to
say that is just the that is just
wonderful thank you thank you so much at
this time I would like to welcome to the
stage dr. Rebecca doors the Glenn
DeVries Dean of the Mellon College of
Science Lena
ladies and gentlemen Dean Rebecca doors
[Applause]
thank you Jim it is my pleasure to
introduce Martha Pollack dr. Pollack is
the 14th president of Cornell University
as faculty at the University of Michigan
dr. Pollack and dr. J hey nian forged a
strong friendship I'm pretty sure that
neither of them imagined that they'd be
here today as president of two of the
best universities in the United States
their presidencies came coming at
important time in history when were
presented with new opportunities and
challenges on a daily basis technology
is moving forward at an amazing pace
it's impacting all areas of research
transforming how we teach and blending
the lines between disciplines dr.
Shahani and Pollock are the right type
of leader at the right time bold
innovative forward-thinking we need to
make our institutions a transport
transformational part of this time since
becoming the president of corn even
Cornell University about a year and a
half ago dr. Pollock has demonstrated a
strong commitment to sustaining and
enhancing Cornell's academic distinction
while enhancing a quality diversity and
inclusivity she is supporting the
university's expansion into New York
City where it has programs that range
from architecture to technology to
medicine dr. Pollack came to Cornell
University from the University of
Michigan where she was provost and
executive vice president for academic
affairs before her tenure at Michigan
she actually served she served on the
University of Pittsburgh's faculty so
welcome back to Pittsburgh
dr. Pollock is renowned for her
contributions in computer science and
artificial intelligence her research
focuses on automated automated planning
temporal reasoning and constraint
satisfaction she has designed
intelligent technology to assist people
with cognitive impairments and their
caregivers dr. Pollock has also served
as president of the Association for the
Advancement of artificial intelligence
and was a member of the Advisory
Committee for the National Science
Foundation's computers and information
science engineering division and a
member of the board of directors of the
computing Research Association please
join me in welcoming dr. Martha Pollack
Thank You Rebecca good morning to all of
you I am truly honored to be here today
for the inauguration of my colleague and
friend Farnum Jahan e'en as the tenth
president of Carnegie Mellon University
most of you probably don't know this but
there's an historical connection between
Carnegie Mellon and my own University
Cornell Andrew Carnegie was one of
Cornell's first trustees elected to that
role in 1890 later honoring his passion
for music
Carnegie donated to Cornell a
magnificent organ to celebrate the 80th
birthday of our first president Andrew
Dickson white alas the organ suffered an
ignoble fate its air intake for some
inexplicable reason was located in the
men's bathroom and in 1935 there was a
plumbing failure that filled that room
with water unaware of this the
university organist sat down at the
instrument and according to the
historical account blew a mighty
crescendo which filled the leather organ
pouches with water ruining them perhaps
we didn't better off with a gift of
bagpipes now there is also a longtime
connection between Farnham amel though
of course not as long as between our
universities as Rebecca said Farnham and
I met about 20 years ago when we were
both faculty members in computer science
and engineering at the University of
Michigan I later became chair of CSC and
Farnam succeeded me in that role later
he became Provost here at Carnegie
Mellon a few years after I had become
Provost at Michigan and he started as
interim president here just a couple of
months after I became Cornell's
president
[Applause]
but I'm gonna take that couple of months
headstart seriously and imagine that it
gives me the right to offer him some
advice on leadership specifically I'd
like to quote hopper the grasshopper in
the animated movie a bug's life
who said this quote first rule of
leadership everything is your fault I
hate to tell you this Farnham but
hoppers right especially when you're the
president of a university but really
having everything be your fault
is a fair trade-off for all that is
wonderful about being a university
president it is as I know Farnum
appreciates a huge privilege to lead a
university especially a great one like
Carnegie Mellon universities are
institutions that are second to none in
changing lives we change the lives of
our students we change the lives of the
communities into which our students
graduate and we change the lives of all
those who are touched by the research
and the scholarship of our faculty
Farnham I can assure you is the perfect
choice to lead Carnegie Mellon and to
ensure that it continues its proud
tradition of changing lives for the
better he has a range of experience
that's an extraordinary fit for this
university experience in academia where
he's been a talented and dedicated
teacher as well as a renowned researcher
whose discoveries have had broad impact
experience in industry where he founded
a very successful network security
startup company and experience in
government where he served in major
roles at the National Science Foundation
the National Research Council's computer
science and telecommunications board and
more but beyond all that what I want you
to know is that Farnham also has a set
of personal characteristics that are
from incomplete alignment with Carnegie
Mellon's culture he is a person of high
integrity who values and exhibits
creativity innovation and
entrepreneurship he values and promotes
mentorship and the development of
leadership skills as essential to
pairing students for today's world he
appreciates the importance of a
university supporting a breadth of
intellectual inquiry but he also has a
particular passion for translational
research that produces results that
directly benefit society he's focused on
the ways in which technology can enhance
all aspects of the university from
teaching to research to operations a few
years ago when Alan G Merton retired
from the presidency of George Mason
University he said this quote do I like
being a university president I don't
know but I do know that I have loved
being George Mason University's
president some of my friends are
university presidents I wouldn't want to
be where they are and they probably
wouldn't want to be here these jobs can
look a lot alike but they are not end
quote search committees look for
university presidents who fit their
University and I can't imagine Carnegie
Mellon finding someone who fits better
than Farnham he will be a brilliant and
inspired leader for this wonderful
University and who knows he may even
learn to play the bagpipes
[Applause]
Thank You president Pollock for your
thoughtful and inspiring words we
appreciate your presence with us here
today my name is Jean Van Driessen I'm
the chair of the faculty organization
and the Duquesne Light Company professor
of civil and environmental engineering
and engineering and public policy I am
joined by Jessica Owens the chair of
staff counsel and the program
coordinator for supplemental instruction
and Excel collaborative learning group
programs
Rashmi Mehta the president of the
student body and a junior in economics
in Dietrich College and The Temper
school and Alex de Claudio the president
of the Alumni Association Board an
alumnus of Heinz and Dietrich colleges
and The Temper School of Business he
also serves on our Board of Trustees
prominent within our University seal is
the Thistle for more than five centuries
the Thistle has stood as the national
emblem of Scotland the birthplace of our
founder Andrew Carnegie among the oldest
still celebrated national emblems in the
world the thistle represents one of the
highest honors an individual can receive
from the community among the Scots it is
bestowed only on those who have made an
outstanding contribution in life it is
our distinct honor to present dr. Joe
Hahn Ian with an especially commissioned
sculpture of a thistle on behalf of the
Carnegie Mellon University community
this token is meant to serve as a
reminder of the attributes within the
CMU community that thistles are said to
embody strength bravery determination
and devotion the first characteristic is
strength our strength is in the work we
do and in our approach to it that is
equal parts fearless and curious this
strength lives in our students
faculty our staff our alumni our
leadership and our board of trustees all
of our hearts are in the work
the second characteristic is bravery
we've got it the people who are John the
Carnegie Mellon view challenges not as
obstacles but as opportunities we
inspire each other to dig in dive deeper
peel back the extra layer continually in
search of breakthroughs that will make a
difference
the next characteristic is determination
we are determined to solve most
difficult questions posed by society in
order to do so we use self motivation
discipline and multiple opportunities to
explore potential solutions that no one
has posed yet
the final characteristic is devotion we
are devoted to Carnegie Mellon we are
devoted to its experimentation its
rigour and research with the human
dimension of purpose and tangible impact
that impact is felt on campus in
Pittsburgh throughout the nation and
across the globe President Joe honey can
you please join us we hope this
sculpture reminds you of these
characteristics inter woven in the CMU
community and your leadership may it
inspire you every day let it forever
commemorate and symbolize this day as we
move forward into the future we are
committed to creating together
[Applause]
what a beautiful representation of all
that is Carnegie Mellon thank you so
much for sharing this beautiful
community gift on behalf of everyone at
CMU thank you the investiture of a
president has held as an academic
ceremony
much like commencement and like
graduation it symbolizes an important
transition a rite of passage today's
ceremony is a rite of passage not only
for dr. johan ian but also for carnegie
mellon new leadership can inspire new
thinking new directions and new
aspirations and i'm confident that under
dr. johan Ian's presidency the
University will take on a fresh group of
challenges and ask new questions dr.
johan ian in faculty marshals will you
please come forward to join me
Farnham John in by the authority of the
Board of Trustees and with the
enthusiastic approval of the faculty
staff students alumni and this
distinguished assembly I present into
your keeping the charter of Carnegie
Mellon University and I also present to
you the Great Seal of the University the
symbol of the high office you now hold
and invest you with all of the rights
privileges and responsibilities of the
office of the President
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of the
Board of Trustees and the members of the
Academy I now present you with the tenth
president of Carnegie University dr.
Farnum Jahan Ian
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you very much
Wow
chairman roar
trustees faculty colleagues students
staff alumni and honored guests good
morning and thank you it's a great honor
and a truly humbling experience to stand
here as the tenth president of Carnegie
Mellon University I hereby accept the
symbols the Office of the President and
all of the responsibilities pertaining
thereto
it brings me great joy to celebrate this
occasion with my family especially my
wife Tris and my children Daniel Thomas
and Sarah who have always been who have
always been my greatest blessing I am so
touched by the presence of friends
former students colleagues and
collaborators who have traveled from
across the country to be here I also
want to acknowledge community partners
and civic leaders from the Pittsburgh
region who are showing their support for
this University today and every day and
I would especially like to thank my dear
friends marlene Berman Keith block and
Martha Pollack for day kind and
thoughtful words this morning Martha
I've been following your footsteps what
you didn't tell them is that you were my
department head and my Provost my boss
for many many years I don't know what
you're planning to do next I'm pretty
happy to be here so don't do anything
else
[Applause]
today's ceremony is a celebration
steeped in tradition the singing of our
national anthem our academic regalia the
iconic sound of bagpipes these rituals
remind us that at this moment is not
about the beginning of my journey as
president rather this ceremony
celebrates our storied history as a
community of scholar in a nation driven
by learning and discovery CMU is
relative V a Young University we've come
so far in such a short time and our
accomplishments would have not been
possible without the leadership of my
predecessors I specially want to
acknowledge and thank president emeritus
Jerry Cohen and past Bravo's
and past Provost mark Hamlet
bored there
for their enduring commitment to this
University we are so grateful to you for
everything you have done for Carnegie
Mellon mark and Jerry of course great
leaders are inspired by an extraordinary
community as Mark and Jerry can attest
countless faculty staff alumni and
partners helped to build a foundation of
excellence CMU enjoys today I am
grateful to all the men and women who
have guided this university since its
founding and who will secure its future
in particular I wish to recognize the
members of Carnegie Mellon's board of
trustees who are disturb dis institution
I am so grateful for their trust they
have placed in me trustees would you
please stand to be recognized Carnegie
Mellon trustees
please be seated I would also like to
acknowledge and thank the university
deans vice provost and executive
management team my co-conspirators who
do so much to advance CMU every day with
the university leadership team please
stand to be recognized
like many of us here I left home as a
teenager to pursue an education as I
prepared for my journey from Iran to
Texas I remember asking my mother to
help me pack
she said pack light
because whatever you need you will find
there pack light because whatever you
need you will find there and so as I
left home with little more than a sense
of optimism and a desire to make the
most of the incredible opportunities
that only an education in the United
States could provide I've carried my
mother's words with me over these many
years I think her advice may have been
based on the hope that I would return
home once the initial excitement wore
off but I was pretty stubborn in fact I
got my tenacity from her along with a
work ethic instilled in me by my father
my siblings were here can attest to that
but looking back perhaps my mother was
hinting at the knowledge I would
accumulate in the journey ahead as a
teacher and advisor I came to understand
the incredible power of Education to
change lives as a researcher mentor
entrepreneur I observed the potential of
a single idea to launch a new enterprise
or disrupt an entire industry and during
my time in public service in Washington
DC
I saw how these ideas had the ideas
emerging from higher education serve as
serve as a foundation of our success as
a nation my 30-year career ultimately
led me here to this city and this
university this community our community
embodies all of my most
servant beliefs and my greatest passions
everyday at CMU I am inspired by you
here the world's most ambitious students
collaborate at the edges and
intersection of diverse fields and go on
to change the world as alumni here
faculty leave an indelible mark on
society through their scholarship here
professionals and dedicated staff create
an environment that support our shared
success these are the people and ideals
that set CMU apart from the very
beginning when Andrew Carnegie founded
the Carnegie technical schools to
educate the sons and daughters of
factory workers in 1900 only it's an
evolution this institution would house
two great learning environments the
College of Engineering and the College
of Fine Arts you see right from the
start we were bringing together
creativity and Industry our willingness
to take risks continued into the 20th
century when we became the first
degree-granting drama institution in the
United States and then when the Mellon
Institute of research founded by Richard
and Mel Andrew Mellon merged with
Carnegie Tech to create Carnegie Mellon
University and again when Newell Simon
perlis and Raj Reddy came to dominate
the emerging field of computer science
and establish artificial intelligence as
the next frontier in human progress
to paraphrase CS pioneer Grace Hopper
the most dangerous phrase in the English
language is we've always done it this
way so at a time when computers were
barely understood we were among the very
first to recognize the power of
computing and we made some big
BET's in 1965 we established our
department of computer science in 1979
we founded the first robotics Institute
at the u.s. university in 1984 we
attracted funding from the federal
government to launch the software
engineering Institute and in 1988 we
announced the first college in the world
devoted solely to computer science ours
is still the model that others follow
in the process we've created new fields
of inquiry such as machine learning
transition design and the science of
learning we magnified our societal
impact through technologies like
autonomous vehicles and additive
manufacturing and we did all of this
while also cleaning up at the Tonys the
Emmys and the Putnam competition
there's a lot to be gained by looking
back at our past we see who we are who
we've always been alumni from those
early years would certainly see
themselves in today's students
entrepreneurial creative collaborative
whip-smart and just a little bit quirky
well the past has left a bright trail
the futures arriving faster than anyone
could have predicted and you've heard
several speakers talk about that our
entire world is adapting to
unprecedented advances that are rapidly
transforming our economy our society and
our culture we must ask ourselves how
can higher education fit into this
dazzling future indeed our industry has
recently come under scrutiny this is not
a new phenomenon academic institutions
have often been seen as or criticised
rather as ivory towers but there is no
doubt that sustained investment in
research and education has fuelled our
nation's broad prosperity since World
War two
[Applause]
universities exemplify our faith in the
power of Education to transcend social
economic and racial divides to reinforce
our role as pillars of progressive
society higher education must approach
our mission with renewed attention to
the unique demands of tomorrow at stake
is the ability of our society to retain
its fundamental commitment of democracy
truth equity and freedom of expression
[Applause]
at carnegie-mellon we have always
responded to challenges with trademark
fearlessness I'm reminded of the
leadership of dick sired who not only
pioneered a new model for business
education as Dean of our business school
but would later serve as one of the most
visionary CMU presidents more than 40
years ago he made bold but calculated
investments in the very areas that
define our leadership today these risks
were not always met with broad support
but that they paid off as a result CMU
grew from a small regional institution
to an international center of higher
education the time to be intentionally
bold is once again upon us we have a
singular opportunity to wield our
exceptional strength and make the next
big investments in our global leadership
let's consider together what society
needs most from academic institutions in
the context of our two core missions
research and education at CMU we advance
human knowledge through scholarly
research and forge new connections to
our humanity through the Arts but the
nature of research and creativity is
rapidly changing increasingly becoming
dependent on people working across the
boundaries of stablished disciplines and
on computational data driven approaches
that are accelerating discovery and
innovation this is precisely where CMU
excels in fact we have cultivated a
distinct leadership where these two
areas intersect at the Nexus of
Technology and society through these
expertise we're enhancing the way we
live work and communicate and we're
shaping modern culture
through visionary art performance and
design CMU legend herb Simon once said
we're not observers of the future we're
actors our job is to design a
sustainable and acceptable world and
bring it about this remains true as true
today as when he said it more than 20
years ago what has also remained
constant is the tremendous
responsibility that comes with this
influence I was reminded of this last
year when I came across an editorial by
David Brooks in the New York Times which
reflected on Pittsburgh's Renaissance of
course our connection to this city is
one of our greatest strengths but this
article while acknowledging CMU's
positive impact also warned of a
so-called Carnegie Mellon layer of
prosperity that had not quite penetrated
working-class neighborhoods indeed we
are witnessing the disenfranchisement of
a growing segment of our population
people who just do not see themselves as
part of this new economy who can't even
imagine a pathway to entry while the
nature of this divide has been debated
by pundits on the left and on the right
this goes far beyond partisan politics
we all bear responsibility for ensuring
that the future we're building works for
everyone
if we succeed the United States will
become will continue to serve as a
shining example of prosperity and
democracy for the rest of the world here
lies the greatest obligation for
institutions of higher learning in the
modern era and a commitment that lies at
the heart of CMU's leadership even as we
break new ground in technology
we must work to mitigate any
consequences that diminish diminish
human dignity and opportunity that is
why at CMU scientists and engineers work
together with philosophers artists
economists who will shape what might be
possible with ethicists humanists and
policy experts who will guide our path
and with the behavioural scientist who
will measure the impact of our work on
humanity reinforcing our distinct is
strength at the Nexus of Technology and
humanity will be crucial to building an
extraordinary momentum in both research
and creativity and as president I am
committed to supporting this leadership
by investing in a diverse community of
faculty and researchers by doubling down
on our partnership beyond the borders of
our campus and by creating vibrant
living laboratories in communities
around the world this is the next
frontier for Carnegie Mellon and I
believe it will only deepen our societal
impact heading into the future
as much as we value or impact on of our
impact of our research and creativity we
are equally committed to our educational
mission and as a CMU parent the
responsibility of preparing the next
generation is deeply personal to me to
the CMU students here and today here
today and also across various campuses
and our our campus watch parties you are
my most important motivation you're
spending your most formative years here
from what I remember from my own college
experience you're undoubtedly
forming lifelong friendships you know
many of my best friends from college are
still my best friends today the
foundation you built here will sustain
you as you enter a world defined by
continuous disruption according to a
recent study about two-thirds of jobs
that you will hold throughout your lives
do not even exist this reality has
dramatic and immediate implications for
the kind of education you deserve today
throughout our history every period of
significant technological change has
been met with a corresponding wave of
innovation in education I'm here to tell
you that right now we are at the dawn of
the next major transformation in
education and Carnegie Mellon will be at
the forefront of these changes from
curriculum to pedagogy to structure and
organization we are reimagining our
education with your futures in mind
we're breaking down disciplinary silos
and launching cross-cutting programs
that better serve your interests and
society's needs programs like behavioral
economics neuroscience and id8
we're embedding continuous learning in
these skills that will only increase in
demand as automation reshapes the future
work skills like communication critical
thinking and entrepreneurship we're
investing in infrastructure doubt
supports the new ways that students
learn and collaborate spaces like pepper
quad and Scott Hall we're utilizing our
expertise in the science of learning to
develop a personalized model of
Education focused on how each of you
learns best every day we work to build
and sustain a community that's inclusive
equitable nurturing for both graduate
and undergraduate students a place where
diverse perspectives can come together
in a culture of civil discourse to our
students thank you for entrusting us
with this most important chapter in your
lives
you will always be at the heart of my
presidency as we consider
as we considered aspirations that unite
this global community
philanthropy must continue to catalyze
and support our forward momentum in fact
this university was founded by an act of
philanthropy at this pivotal moment I am
delighted today to announce two
extraordinary new commitments that will
provide critical resources to Carnegie
Mellon in recent years Carnegie Mellon
has been making significant investments
for our College of Engineering including
a state-of-the-art maker ecosystem that
serves the entire campus today I'm
pleased to announce that the Allegheny
Foundation has committed a 30 million
dollar lead grant toward the
transformation of Scafe Hall into a
modern new home for our mechanical
engineering department
this grant the largest in the history of
Allegheny foundation will enable us to
bring our total infrastructure
investments in engineering or the last
decade to more than a quarter billion
dollars but this commitment CMU will be
better able to compete for betters best
students and faculty driving Pittsburgh
reputation as a hub for innovation we're
joined today by Matt Grohl president and
chairman of Allegheny foundation please
join me join me in thanking Allegheny
foundation for their generosity to
Carnegie Mellon Matt please stand to be
recognized
at a time when college education has
never been more important many
prospective students and middle-class
families feel as though they're simply
priced out of education that they may
need for the future this is why CMU has
made growing our endowment for
scholarship fellowships and financial
aid one of our most important strategic
priorities today I'm pleased to announce
that CMU trustee Todd Johnson and his
wife Cindy have committed fifty million
dollars to create an endowment to
support undergraduate scholarship and
student success
[Applause]
you know um I made the announcement a
couple of times yesterday and I said
this last night every time I'm making
this announcement when I get to the word
student I choke up that's why we're here
Todd and Cindy will you stand please to
be recognized
[Applause]
well I lost my place boy I didn't
realize this speech was this long I know
that tell me about it well back to the
place that I lost track of time
this support work will greatly expand
our ability to ensure that a Carnegie
Mellon education is within the reach of
all talented students this gift the
largest towards scholarship support in
Carnegie Mellon's history was inspired
by Todd's own path to success here at
CMU and the fellowship that funded his
education please once again join me in
thanking and congratulating the Johnsons
for their generosity and commitment to
our students Todd and Cindy we are so
grateful to you for your generosity
I hope you packed a good lunch this is a
long speech
my fellow Tartans whether you're in
Pittsburgh Silicon Valley Australia
Rwanda or Qatar I hope you are as
excited as I am about the future of
Carnegie Mellon University to be part of
CMU at this moment is to be at the cusp
of the next great phase of societal and
human development if we continue doing
what we do today we'll maintain momentum
and continue to be a great University
but if we are very intentional if we are
unapologetically bold and if we are
committed to taking risks I am confident
that we will position ourselves among
the top tier institutions in the world a
place that's known for the writing the
story of this century an institution
dedicated to anticipating and solving
the most pressing challenges facing
humanity through creative inquiry
through scientific discovery through the
impact of technology and through a
transformative education that changes
lives as we embark on this exhilarating
future together we do so as a community
bond to bound together by a set of core
values that serve as our foundation
integrity knowledge compassion respect
the great scientist Albert Einstein
understood this fundamental connection
between excellence and human values in
1950 he wrote only morality in our
actions can give beauty and dignity to
law
to make this a living force and bring it
to clear consciousness is perhaps the
foremost task of education Andrew
Carnegie put it a little bit more simply
my heart is in the work each one of us
has a role to play in bringing beauty
and dignity to our mission through the
impact we make on society the leaders we
develop and opportunities we create for
others I am I feel privileged to work
with such outstanding partners and I
look forward to all that we will achieve
together thank you very much
[Applause]
I hereby declare this inauguration of
the tenth president of Carnegie Mellon
University to be concluded the audience
is requested to remain at your seats
until the completion of the recession
and now please rise for the singing of
the alma mater
which will be sung by members of the
School of Music
[Music]
[Applause]
you